Cameron McLain:
There can be no floor without the sky. Blue darkening of the deepest, deepest kind.
All you know is one day you will die.
Chris Ghaffari:
I'm Chris Ghaffari, and I'm the director of "This is Our Youth." I chose the play for
a lot of reasons. First, it's a play about kids our age. And what's really cool about
Chris Ghaffari:
it is that we have actors who are playing their age.
Lindsey Rose Aguero-Sinclair:
I'm Lindsey Rose. I'm playing Jessica in "This Is Our Youth." Jessica is an aspiring fashion designer.
She's my age she's living in the city. She goes to F.I.T.
Matt Seely:
I'm Matt Seely. I'm playing Warren Straub in "This Is Our Youth." I think it just speaks
to what were doing now and what we're doing here at college. We don't have to know what
Matt Seely:
we're going to do. Everything we're doing is building to that.
Dan Yawitz:
My name is Dan Yawitz. I'm playing Dennis Ziegler in "This Is Our Youth." Dennis is
a 21-year-old college dropout in 1982, living in a one-bedroom apartment in the Upper West
Dan Yawitz:
Side of Manhattan, which his parents pay for, and he just sort of lives off of selling drugs.
His best friend is Warren Straub, who, during the play, comes to crash with him for a little while.
Chris Ghaffari:
Rehearsing has been interesting, because we have been able to draw on some of the experiences
of our actors.
Lindsey Rose Aguero-Sinclair :
Certain circumstances are very similar. I mean, being from New York, going to a private school.
Dan Yawitz:
He's a white, Jewish, upper-middle-class guy from the Upper West Side of Manhattan,
oddly similar to myself.
Chris Ghaffari:
With the set, we wanted to create a small space. We wanted to give the actors minimal space
and force the characters to deal with each other.
Matt Seely:
Because there's usually only two of us on stage at any given time, we can play around
with the space that we're given. We don't have to coordinate all of our movements. It's
Matt Seely:
nice. It's freeing. Even though it's a small space, it's very freeing to be natural.
Dan Yawitz:
I think this play is incredibly relevant to Princeton students. It's a play about kids
who have come from means but don't really take advantage of what they have, and at Princeton
Dan Yawitz:
we're really in a place where we have so much and so much is at our fingertips, but what
we choose to do with that and how we choose to use that is really up to us. So, I think
Dan Yawitz:
that the play could be seen as a challenge to Princeton students to use what we have
and make the best of what we have.
Lindsey Rose Aguero-Sinclair:
This is our youth.
Matt Seely:
Dan Yawitz:
This is our youth.
[music]